this episode was made possible by
audible get a free audio book of your
choice with a 30-day free trial at
audible.com slash second thought this is
bagel we think he's a healer pit mix and
he's about as far from a wolf as you can
get he's very obedient super friendly
and not aggressive at all we know that
humans played a role in creating the
modern domesticated dog but how exactly
did we go from a wild fearsome and
capable hunter to these guys all right
so we're on our way to the Fort Worth
Zoo and we're gonna meet with somebody
who can give us a bit more information
on when dogs became a genetically
distinct group from wolves I'm super
excited because there's a chance I'll
actually get to meet a wolf in person
which is awesome I love animals this is
going to be cool couple fun facts while
we're driving first a lot of people
think that some dog breeds like Alaskan
Malamutes and Huskies are a lot closer
to their wolf ancestors than other
breeds that's actually not the case
everything from chihuahuas to Great
Danes all differ from their common
ancestor by about the same degree of
separation also contrary to popular
belief modern dogs did not come from any
of the living wolf species we see today
the gray wolf is the closest currently
living relative to modern dogs but their
ancestors are actually thought to be an
extinct form of wolf that lived during
the Late Pleistocene era one other fact
that I think is really cool is that we
didn't just befriend these ancient
wolves once which then spread around the
world nope we did it twice
simultaneously in completely different
regions the current thinking is that an
initial population split into East and
West Eurasian wolves these were then
domesticated separately before the
Wolves went extinct our best estimate
for this event is anywhere between
14,000 and 6400 years ago this Western
population was then slowly and partially
replaced by the eastern population as
humans brought them West ok so not 10
minutes before I got here I got a call
from our wolf expert saying she needed
to reschedule kind of a pain since we
drove all the way out here but hopefully
I'll be able to come back out and
reschedule it before this video goes
live but since we're here let's go find
some wolves
well that was a tremendous waste of time
took about an hour to find the wolf
enclosure I got there turns out it was
too hot for him and he was now honestly
the whole visit was kind of just sad
there was a Jaguar and a coyote just
kind of pacing across their 10-foot
enclosure I don't know if I'm gonna come
back here okay here's a happier place to
record dog park should have probably
come here in the first place for as much
time as we spend with dogs and as much
as we know about them as a species the
scientific community is still divided on
a lot of their history were they really
domesticated twice or was there just one
initial population and we've missed some
of the evidence when did the modern dog
as we know it really separate from its
wolf brethren since ancient dogs and
wolves are so similar in body size and
structure and we have limited fossil
evidence it's very hard to tell when the
real turning point was obviously it was
a gradual process but as of right now we
can't even narrow down the potential
timeline to anywhere less than a several
thousand year span one point of
contention that some people have with a
statement we made earlier in the video
is that there are some dog breeds that
are less changed physically from wolves
than others yes a husky definitely has
more wolf like features than a teacup
poodle the distance from their wolf
ancestors is roughly the same it's just
some dog breeds have been selectively
bred away from those wolf like traits if
you're looking for the least changed dog
breeds currently living you'd be right
to guess husky and Malamute but the list
also includes the chow chow Akita and
Shiba Inu but let's get down to the big
question where did dogs really come from
as we've learned we don't know the exact
timeframe but we do know that they were
the very first domesticated life-form
before food animals before crops and
most definitely before cats domesticated
us all of humanity's other domestication
endeavors came after we had settled into
an agricultural lifestyle the evidence
we have suggests that wolves first began
to cooperate with humans while we were
still hunter-gatherers this is where
things get a little foggy how exactly
did we make friends with these dangerous
animals popular opinion used to be that
we mighty humans established our
dominance over the Wolves and forced
them to work for us but more recently
it's been suggested that the Wolves may
have domesticated themselves hunting for
food is hard and takes tremendous
amounts of energy scavenging is easier
especially when you have a tribe of
humans nearby who always seem to have
piles of meat on hand some experts
believe that the more inquisitive and
trusting
we'll slowly got accustomed to human
activity and began stealing bits of food
and eventually accepting food from the
humans over the generations these
friendly wolves became more docile more
trusting of humans and eventually began
to live among them somewhere along the
line these will stop interacting with
their wilder counterparts and became a
distinct group these newly domesticated
canines were used as hunting partners
guard dogs and eventually just
companions humans slowly bred them for
desirable traits despite how closely we
associate dogs with barking it actually
wasn't a common trait in early dogs they
would howl whimper and growl like wolves
but dogs were selectively bred for their
willingness to bark thus creating an
effective guard dog
over the centuries dogs became less work
oriented and more often seen as family
pets we began to breed them for
appearance or for intelligence or
temperament the results are pretty
apparent there are at least three
hundred forty different breeds today and
more designer dogs are being invented
pretty frequently we've had two new
breeds recognized by the American Kennel
Club just this year the question of when
exactly dogs became genetically distinct
from wolves has puzzled scientists for
decades but over the years we've slowly
pieced together a more complete history
of our favorite furry friends we may not
ever know the full story but at least we
can all agree that we're glad a few
friendly wolves decided to introduce
themselves if you want to learn more
about the history of dogs
check out audibles huge selection of
audio books I can personally recommend
domesticated by Richard C Francis it
explains how without our domestication
of plants and animals human civilization
as we know it wouldn't exist the author
discusses agriculture food animals and
of course man's best friend and how it
pays to be domesticated in a world
dominated by humans you can get this
book or another of your choice
completely free when you start a free
trial with audible I like audible
because instead of having to sit down
and actively read books I can listen to
them while I'm out running errands or
driving to the zoo or playing frisbee
with my dogs
audible helps you listen to more books
by letting you switch seamlessly between
devices picking up exactly where you
left off whether it's on your phone
through your car from a tablet or at
home on an Amazon echo you can get
through tons of books hands and eyes
free while doing almost anything
audible members get a credit every month
good for any audiobook you are - of
price and unused credits roll over to
the next month didn't like your
audiobook you can exchange it no
questions asked
plus your books are yours to keep with
audible you can go back and re-listen
anytime even if you cancel your
membership
a 30-day trial and your first audio book
is free visit audible.com slash second
thought or text second thought to 500
500
I know this episode was a very different
style than my usual content so be sure
to let me know what you think in the
comments below if this is your first
time visiting consider subscribing to
keep up to date with the latest content
and click the bell so you get notified
for each new video as always thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week